troublan on va passer à Anne hiidalgo
après les révélations sur son voyage en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et à Tahiti Anne
hiidalgo doit-elle démissionner puisque
c'est un voyage qui a coûté près de
60000 € la mère de Paris est rentrée
hier et elle a enfin décidé de
communiquer sur ce voyage regardez on en
parle ensemble et énormément le demande
la démission d'go Gill Verdez regardez
c'est un déplacement à près de 60000 €
qui embarrasse la mairie de Paris celui
d'an dalgo ces derniers jours en
Polynésie au programme rencontre des
élus locaux lutte contre la montée des
eos et surtout visite du site olympique
des épreuves de surf pourtant la mer de
paris ne s'est pas rendu sur les lieux
et a poursuivi son voyage dans les îles
par une visite familiale annidalgo
autorise un voyage opaque à Tahiti avec
une délégation plétorique mais quel lien
avec Paris et les Parisiens je trouve
qu'on fait vraiment une polémique de
tout et je pense que le soufflet va
assez vite retomber alors est-ce que le
soufflet va assez vite retomber je crois
pas je sais pas si elle doit
démissionner mais pour ne pas démission
à mon avis elle doit tout rembourser
dans ces caslà pour moi c'est la seule
manière là elle a remboursé le billet de
retour il y a confusion entre voyage
officiel visite privée pour moi dans ces
caslà vous remboursez l'allée le retour
les hôtels sur place et tout sin 600
boules non c'est pour 6 ça part part
pour moi les aut vont fa non les autres
ils étai eux ils étaient pas voyage
privé elle été voir sa fille elle a pris
des vacances pour voir sa fille au terme
du voyage officiel alors y a le
communiqué de la maie de Paris dis
depuis quelques jours ce déplacement
sucite une attention particulière les
parisiennes et les Parisiens ont le
droit de disposer d'informations fiabl
factuell et transparente à son sujet
coût du déplacement
40955 € de transport pour 6 personnes
18545 € de frais d'hébergement et de
restauration ce qui nous fait donc 60000
€ la mer de Paris voilà le coût du
transport de l'ensemble de la délégation
des trois élus et de trois
collaborateurs qui les accompagnaient
s'est établi pour l'ensemble des vols
Paris Nea et les frais d'hébergement
voilà donc ils ont ils ont communiqué
mais qu'est-ce que à quoi ça sert fa 25
versions différentes et puis c dans
communiqué qui qui est très mal rédigé à
un moment on voit comme justification
délirante paris est une ville
ultramarine elle rassemble une
population très nombreuse venant de tous
les départements et territoire d'outrem
les 53 agents de la Ville de Paris plus
de 6000 d'entre eux sont originaires des
outremèes mais quel est le rapport mais
c'est une c'est une énorme Dar on dirait
on dirait un enfant que tu surprends
avec le doigt dans le pot de confiture
c'est elle a changé 12 fois de
versionelle s fa CR on se demande aussi
ce qu'elle a essayé de faire aussi parce
que quand elle était là-bas publiaé des
photos de Paris alors qu'elle était
là-bas donc on se dit est-ce qu'elle a
essayé de cacher quelque chose surtout
la communication finale qui est de dire
qu'elle pa la moitié parce que donc
c'est à moitié un vis un voyage privé ça
ne cache pas le fait queelle n'y serait
pas allée si sa fille n'avait pas été
expatriée là-bas elle aurait pas hab
tout ça de propos le sondage oui 91 %
doit-elle démissionner oui à
91% c'est qu'elle a réussi êtrelu he
c'est fou 91% et en plus c'est une
championne des voyages elle a quand même
fait une vingtaine de voyages depuis à
l'étranger depuis qu'elle a été élue
donc quelqu'un qui est très écologiste
et qui se dit voilà très éc c'est la
confusion argent public argent privé ça
les Français supportent pas allez on va
parler de Raquel garido mise en retrait
4 mois par la France insoumise euh
regardez est-ce qu'ils ont eu raison ou
pas 4 mois comme Adrien catn ouis ouais
pour des faits beaucoup plus graves et 4
mois elle prend 4 mois aussi Raquel
alors que B éit hors du groupe pas elle
regarder la conférence de presse de
Mathilde Panou c'est toujours une
souffrance de la regarder
bah ça c'est vrai il est faux de dire
que Madame garido aurait été sanctionné
pour avoir critiqué ou pour avoir juste
exprimer ses
idées mais pour des accumulations
d'agissement et de propos répétés qui
nuisent au bon fonctionnement du groupe
notamment je vous relis ce que nous
avons écrit la diffusion de fausse
information dans la presse à propos du
groupe ou de ses membres la mise en
cause et le dénigrement annominem de
plusieurs membres du groupe la prise à
partie de salariés du groupe
parlementaire voilà donc ça n'a rien à
voir avec le fait d'avoir exprimé oui ou
non des idées ou des critiques voilà
c'est toujours une galère hein
d'entendre math pano comprend rien de ce
qu'elle dit et François Rufin en plus l'
contredit parce qu'il a il a fait un
tweet en disant Raquel garido est en
désaccord sur l'absence de démocratie
dans la France insoumise donc il dit que
le le propos même pour lequel on on va
la sanctionner c'est parce qu'elle est
en désaccord et comment notre mouvement
qui prône la 6e République lui répond
non par un débat mais par une sanction
alorsel garido elle est vénère hein euh
verdict de la Cour pénale des insoumis
euh 4 mois 4 mois cela vous dit quelque
chose c'est comme Adrien catnin pendant
4 mois je n'ai plus le droit de
représenter mon groupe parlementaire en
tant cororatrice dans les discussions
générales en commission des lois et dans
l'émicycle je n'ai plus le droit de
poser des questions au gouvernement au
nom de mon groupe je suis mis au banc
pourquoi parce que j'ai tenu bon sur le
principe de non cumule des mandats parce
que j'ai voulu que les moyens du groupe
parlementaire bon voilà elle est bon
elle elle est à mon avis elle reviendra
plus mais il faut qu'elle parte avec fin
avec clémentinotin il faut qu'il parte
il faut que là c'est un narage de
l'autre côé c'est ils sont dur là à
écouter là que ce soit Mélenchon mathde
Panau toute l'équipe là flemme la base
est plutôt avec Madame garido hein ouais
flemme absolue ouis la base les vrais
électeurs ouais ou en tous les cas c'est
un parti qui ne sa'est pas prê pas faire
preuve d'ouverture c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire euh et moi je trouve que ça
ressemble à des process staliniens c'est
tu n'es pas dans la ligne donc tu sors
c'est c'est c'est tout sauf ce que doit
être un parti politique où la
contradiction doit permettre de faire
avancer les choses non non merci non tu
vas toujours voter pour eux ou pas mais
moi je suis pour la sanction à gauche
elle va pas te lâcher ave ça
la pour la sanction lui il est pour la
sanction bien sûr quoi mais bien sûr
pour la sanction VO j'ai relancé le
débatvo mais vraiment j'allais passer à
un autre sujet bravo passer à côté de ça
déjà tu déjà tu t'avances pas comme
ça excusez-moi est-ce que je peux vous
poser une question bien sûr avec grand
plaisir je balance dans la presse je dis
cyil Hanouna ne fait que nuire à Touche
pas à mon poste c'est plus possible il y
en a marre et cetera je vais te dire je
reste ici c'est pas 4 mois que tu prends
c'est 4 ans
ben merci et ben merci voilà quand vous
balancez ça sur votre patron Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ne fait que nuire vous ne
pouvez pas rester vous n'êtes que
sanctionné ce qui a tué le Parti
socialiste c'est leseffondeurs donc
Mélenchon ne veut pas de ça on peut pas
tolérer ça dans un parti vous êtes
dedans vous êtes dehors moi les gars moi
je peux plus donner mon avis ma Ken non
l'exemple il est mauvais plusieurs fois
tu t'embrouillis ici avec des chroniur
ils ont quitter le plateau ça s
embrouillit en loge on s'est engueulit
plusieurs fois même moi avec bah oui B
alors
s' et le lendemain
on cé si g demain dans la presse dit
cyil Hanouna ne fait que nuire ne fait
que nuire qu'est-ce que tu as ditpm
c'est elle a dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne
fait c Hanouna ne fait que nuire Touche
pas à mon poste depuis 10 mois ou mais
sauf que c'est pas vrai ouais bah oui
est Rais
alors trouver un argument bisé tout
dismoi c'est catastrophique pour son
parti pardon et même depuis des années
tu peux pas transposer les choses ça n'a
rien à voir
là là vous ne savez plus quoi
répondre tu comparesoun à Mélenchon ça
absolument aucun
Rapp mais oui mais d'accord mais sauf
que a pas il y a pas une
fractureex il y a pas une fracture entre
cyil Hanouna et nous alors que là il y a
une fracture au sein de la France
insoumise entre une petite parti parle
pas du fond je te parle du titre dans la
PR non mais réfléchis essaie d'aller un
peu plus loin tu as fait ton numéro de
claquette là avec ton truc et si cétait
si je disais voilà casse publiquement
son patron ne fait pas ça j'ai une
question à vous poser est-ce qu'il y a
une fracture nous non fr non voilà donc
c'est pas comparable c'est bien tu as
fait ton numéro de claquette mais ça
rien à voiras ton émission card
[Applaudissements]
tion dis ça pourquoi tu dis ça il vous a
bien défendu il aura une belle émission
bravo bravo bravo
Charles Charles pas trop Charles j'aV
envie d'appeler Charles le subconscient